we filmed in 65 millimeter negative this
is the third time we've done that we did
a IMAX film back in the mid-80s and then
we did barack in the early 90s which we
shot in 65 output in 70 millimeter
prints and this film was shot in 65
again but we took it into a digital
output DCP at high res scan at 8k so
it's a lot of it's a kind of a
combination of 50 year old Panavision
camera system and cutting-edge digital
technology to output this way and
there's a lot of advantages to using
that combination of technologies now the
image is our main character and so what
we wanted was the fidelity the range
that the 65 format gave us to bring back
the essence of the locations and the
portraits the film is really as a
nonverbal guided meditation on birth
death and rebirth and what we were
trying to show is the flow the inner
connection so we needed the high-res
image to move you through the film we we
scanned our negative our 65 millimeter
negative into a digital at 8k resolution
it was a file that was huge it was a 30
terabyte file of the image and then that
it gets boiled down but to up to a 4k
and you know I don't know if everyone
here is aware but these are new
projectors that were just installed this
week's serendipitously for us the
Academy so we're very excited that was
it was ready in time for our
presentation in 4k so but when we did
baraka when we put out the blu-ray for
baraka we did the same process and
really had an amazing result with the
amount of detail that's retained in the
digital file and realized that the all
the quality of that shooting in that
larger negative ends up in the digital
file on that's why we've output this
time there's so many advantages to doing
it this way I know we consider ourself
film guys I know there's a digital
versus film controversy going on but
when we're doing this hybrid now we love
that every audience sees this film as a
first generation print there's no
scratches no
heard every every showing of this film
is pristine because of that output you
know Baraka was about humanity's
relationship to the eternal and this is
really trying to take it a step further
and the word samsara is a Tibetan
sanskrit word for the wheel of life or
it can also be about impermanence in
that flow when you cut five or six
images together in a cutting room you
know suddenly a narrative is formed just
just on its own and what we try to do is
steer it away from that and move it into
the middle so it's more about the flow
of the image from subject to subject
even though some of these images are
very powerful it's when they break that
flow you've got people in cages and
animals and cages and walls around
religions and dolls are replicate humans
it's the it's all there it's all part of
the flow but we weren't trying to say
this is good or bad right or wrong we
were just trying to move through it and
we're not trying to tell again you know
right or wrong or good or bad there's
there's a lot of complex issues that are
raised from the imagery you know when
you see and when we were in that chicken
factory with a pic uniforms I mean you
know you you look at that it you know
terrific work very tough jobs six days a
week and I you know they found that they
make about hundred fifty ehlers a month
it's very difficult work was very cold
in there and you just say you know is
but they need those jobs I mean you
can't say that's a bad you don't say
good or bad about it you know it is and
you want the audience to understand that
and feel that and you know we're not
looking to make to try to provide
answers to the world's problems here we
just want you know people to feel what's
going on out there